we have been around each other too many
times for me not to know that you were a
dancer oh well yeah yes yes but I don't
tell people that oh I'm sorry let's go
ahead and bring up this photo yep look
at that CH oh look at out to play
Oh I had no idea wait Kelly that was 50
lbs ago whatever if you can measure Time
by weight accumulated wait were you
talking like that to the
dancers no no I was a performing member
of three different dance companies in my
day that's amazing in another day in a
different chapter of my life yeah groovy
and you can Groove I like well no I lik
it there's nothing like dance shape
because you're strong you're limber
you're flexible yeah and graceful and so
totally just like me just like just like
me that's what I say by the way when um
when I was dancing by the way I was
still studying astrophysics and and and
I had fellow dancers who were making
extra money cuz I needed money cuz they
weren't paid much yeah and one of them
said why don't you come down with us
that they cuz they some of them danced
at a strip club oh like a GU Club where
the women you have a picture no
no no no no no but I just want to like
clarify make it my birthday no let me
clarify that so I went and I I was cut
and flex I could do a full split so I
was but but I but I went to just
investigate right I wanted data first so
I go there data yeah yes so I'm watching
them come out and they had asbest lined
jock straps that had been ignited with
lighter fluid and they came out dancing
to Jerry Lee Lewis's song Great Balls of
Fire now now now now let me just say let
me just say let me just say I'm
embarrassed that only in that moment
when I saw their genitals on fire did I
say maybe I should be a math tutor maybe
there's another way before that but
that's stupid I got you're using your
dance skills I could totally tutor math
and it didn't occur to me so I'm GNA be
honest with you like I've never been to
a strip club not against them do your
thing but I've never been to one but
like if I were to go to one I don't
think a lot of balls are being on fire
at a lot of them I think that was a very
specific strip club it was it was I I
I'm just saying at that point I had
other thoughts about how to earn money
you're like I'm going to keep this junk
safe
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home